all right there's a ton of information
to cover tonight now we're going to go
point by point through the memo we're
going to give you important background
information so we can fully explain just
how massive the scandal is everything
that you're going to hear well a lot of
it should sound familiar because we have
been uncovering this piece by piece
every single night now for months we've
been way ahead of the curve but there is
new vital information that is even more
damning more damaging than anything
we've told you so far and as we have
been explaining this is Watergate times
a thousand you're about to find out why
and here are the key findings from the
memo that we're going to cover in detail
here's what you need to know the FBI
deep state officials they used a Hillary
Clinton campaign bought and paid for
dossier that was filled with Russian
lies Russian propaganda totally
unverified to lie to a Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court to
obtain a warrant so they could spy on
Trump campaign adviser Carter page now
during that FISA warrant process the FBI
or at least the upper echelon not the
rank and file repeatedly never told the
FISA judges that the phony salacious
dossier was financed by Hillary Clinton
in the DNC in other words they purposely
omitted crucial information from the
FISA Court judge so they can continue
this process James Comey Andrew McCabe
Sally Yates dana bent a-rod Rosenstein
they are all complicit in this because
they at different points they all
approved surveillance on page now this
part is shocking the FBI then used a
Yahoo News report that was written by
Michael Isikoff from September 23rd 2016
about a quarter page trip to Russia as
evidence to corroborate information in
the phony Russian paid-for dossier
here's the thing and this is critically
important the source for the information
and the Yahoo news report was none other
than Christopher Steele the same author
of the dossier that they were using so
the FBI used Steele's leaked to Yahoo to
corroborate that
see a created by the same person steel
this is what we call circular reporting
because the FBI was pretending that they
had two sources when in fact it was the
same source and they were presenting
that to the judge now the memo was also
exposing how Christopher Steele the
former British spy that according to
reports was known to pay Russian sources
had previously worked closely with the
FBI was suspended and then terminated as
an FBI source for leaking to the press
about his relationship with the bureau
we also know independently from the memo
that in September 2016 Steele and fusion
GPS briefed in person in person
so-called journalists from The New York
Times and The Washington Post in Yahoo
News in The New Yorker in CNN about the
Hillary Clinton phony Russian dossier
and Glenn Simpson testified that both
the Clinton campaign in the DNC were
well aware about this press outreach
they all knew it was a lie so in other
words Hillary Clinton wanted the media
to run with this total false fabricated
dossier hoping to lie to the American
people and convince you that's a reason
to vote for her and not Donald Trump now
let's get back to the memo now still
maintained a close relationship with the
now demoted Department of Justice
official Bruce or now remember or is the
guy who had an office four doors down
from Rod Rosenstein and was removed from
his position for not disclosing that he
met with fusion GPS both before and
after the election now Bruce's wife all
her name is Nellie or she worked for
fusion GPS she was hired to dig up dirt
on Donald Trump for the dossier and also
revealed that during September 2016
Steele said he was quote desperate this
is steel that Donald Trump not get
elected and was passionate about him not
being president I thought we didn't like
Outsiders influential influencing our
elections now according to the memo none
of this was disclosed to the FISA Court
which is a massive problem I can't wait
to hear from the FISA judge and this
also points out in the memo
that during the initial application for
the FISA warrant the head of the FBI
counterintelligence division said the
corroboration of the steel dossier was
quote in its infancy in other words that
means the FBI never corroborated any of
this but they still presented it to a
FISA Court to get a warrant to spy on an
opposition candidate when one candidate
paid for those lives and this is the
part that is massive the memo explains
how former Deputy FBI director Andrew
McCabe testified before the House
Intelligence Committee that the FISA
warrant to spy would not have been
approved without the dossier so when you
put all this information together here's
what it all means the FBI misled and
purposely deceived a federal court while
using an unverified completely phony
opposition research bought and paid for
by Hillary Clinton to spy on an
opposition campaign during a
presidential election all to help one
candidate out all to mislead the
American people now that type of abuse
of power that type of corruption that's
reading of the Constitution it is
unprecedented in American history now
the FISA laws which are all about your
government spying on American people
they have been abused and literally to
surveil on an opposition campaign to
undermine later a duly elected president
we have never ever in history seen
anything like this and it was
spearheaded not by rank-and-file members
of the FBI intelligence community and
Department of Justice no high-ranking
officials James Comey Andrew McCabe rod
Rosenstein Peter struck Lisa page likely
Loretta Lynch and we could also tell you
tonight many others we will be learning
about in coming days many will be
implicated in this but here's the bottom
line
crimes have been committed there is no
way that they did not know that the FBI
was lying to a FISA Court in order to
spy in an opposition campaign during in
an election year they have aided and
abetted what is a massive constitutional
violation call me make
aybe Rosenstein and others all need to
be investigated investigated and in many
cases prosecuted to the fullest extent
of the law
because these crimes have been committed
remember homie testified under oath the
dossier was salacious and unverified
memory told that to donald trump when he
was the president-elect if that's the
case then why the hell that he used it
two months earlier to get a FISA warrant
now of course Comey is running scared
he's out of his mind right now now that
he is exposed with this memo he actually
tweeted out today that's it dishonest
misleading memo wrecked the house Intel
committee destroyed trust with
intelligence community damage
relationship with the FISA Court and an
excusably exposed classified
investigation of an American citizen for
what do J and FBI must keep doing their
jobs here's the problem the only thing
that was dishonest and misleading in
this was Jim Comey and as I said last
night Jim you might want to keep your
mouth shut because anything you say can
and will be used against you in the
court of law and you do have the right
to an attorney
and speaking of Rosenstein now remember
this is a guy that appointed the special
counsel because remember the Attorney
General recused himself he appointed
robert muller he should now resign
immediately because his actions now
prove he is incapable of honestly
serving the American people as a Deputy
Attorney General and here's another
massive revelation that I want you to
think about the entire foundation of
what we've now have gone through this
mess for a year no evidence Trump Russia
collusion the Special Counsel it's been
built on lies and built on a phony fake
news dossier that was funded by Hillary
Clinton now that the FBI then used that
to target then the Trump campaign then
an incoming president now if this never
happened there would be no robert muller
and these revelations are so profound
this corruption so deep it is so obvious
that the special counsel needs to be
shut down immediately and that's not
even taking into account
Muller's massive conflicts of interest
himself and how
steam is filled with Oh big Democratic
donors and people like Andrew Weissman
that withhold exculpatory information in
cases and gets overturned nine zero in
the Supreme Court sends people to jail
overturn Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals
molars investigation is and has been a
witch-hunt from the very beginning it's
built on a house of cards and tonight it
is crashing down look if we as a country
if we care about the Constitution if we
believe in civil liberties if we believe
in those protections then the special
counsel must be disbanded immediately
and by the way nobody else will say this
all charges against Paul Manafort and
General Michael Flynn need to be dropped
it's that simple
President Trump by the way is reacting
to all this breaking news now here's
what he said about the memo take a look
I think it's terrible you want another
truth I think it's a disgrace what's
going on in this country I think it's a
disgrace the memo was sent to Congress
it was Declassified Congress will do
whatever they're going to do but I think
it's a disgrace what's happening in our
country
and when you look at that and you see
that and so many other things what's
going on a a lot of people should be
ashamed of themselves and much worse
than that
so I sent it over to Congress and they
will do what they're going to do
whatever they do is find it was
Declassified and let's see what happens
but a lot of people should be ashamed
more than ashamed a lot of people broke
the law it's more than a shame this is
so deep in its corruption it should
shatter the conscience of law-abiding
American citizens now Fox News is also
reporting tonight that the memo is being
sent to the Department of Justice and
the Inspector General which could in
fact lead eventually to criminal charges
we have also been reporting that this
memo believe it or not is only about 15%
of what's coming this scandal is only in
phase one now congressman Devin Nunez he
told Bret Baier tonight that more memos
are coming stay tuned tick-tock and also
tonight now that this memo has been
released look we've been telling you
about this for a very long time it was
March of last year when we first
reported that there was a FISA warrant
on Trump Tower everything that we have
been talking about and uncovering for a
year on this program is now being shown
to be true and exposed in the meantime
all this while the liberal mainstream
media they have wasted an entire year
holding this country hostage with a
false narrative based on a conspiracy
theory that President Trump colluded
with the Russians they have and have had
no evidence whatsoever because it
doesn't exist the media has been corrupt
and lying to you the American people at
the end of the day they're nothing but
propaganda
an extension of the Democratic Party and
tinfoil hat conspiracy theorists that
are so pathologically locked into their
hate of President Trump they don't know
any better at this point all the
information we have been reporting now
on this has been out there but you have
overpaid journalists just too lazy to
rigidly ideological to do their jobs
they've been sitting on the sidelines
while the biggest scandal in their
lifetimes has been unfolding right
before their very faces now we've been
talking about this issue FISA abuse
spying on the Trump campaign since March
6 of last year and the media has ignored
it every step of the way here's what I
said that day back on my radio show in
March of last year this is the swamp
Obama holdovers life-long bureaucrats
that are sabotaging this is the shadow
government I've been talking about this
is what deep state means they are
sabotaging the Trump presidency a
cardinal rule of the Obama
administration was no White House
official ever interfered with an
independent investigation led by the
Department of Justice that's not a
denial that it happened meaning the FISA
Court requests and it says that as a
matter of practice neither the President
or any White House official ever ordered
surveillance on any US citizen any
suggestion others didn't order it that
doesn't mean it didn't happen and that
doesn't mean Obama didn't know that it
happened we've known the whole time we
were right we've taken a lot of heat for
telling the truth but the evidence the
facts the truth that's what we should
pursue it's all there it's been there
the media doesn't care about any of this
they want president Trump to fail
otherwise they would be reporting on the
story instead of ignoring it and now by
the way they're doing everything they
can do to try and discredit it it's not
going to work now here's the thing facts
are facts truth is truth the media
cannot twist and distort truth and you
the American people and those of you
that have supported this show we thank
you tonight because you imparted me this
possible
you called your congressmen and
Congresswomen you asked them to release
the memo and they did and sadly it does
shock the conscience